Speaker 1: . Let's talk a little bit about
Florida.
We have I mean, I guess I would sort of call
this good news out of Florida in the sense
that in politics you often get reverse consequences.
So, like, think back to the 2016 Republican
primary, which really started in 2015.
Donald Trump arrived with no experience, no
reasonable ideas, no credible path to getting
anything done.
And he was rewarded by becoming the Republican
nominee and ultimately president of the United
States.
And similarly, we have seen in the state of
Florida radical covid Governor Ron DeSantis
experience the covid health SCAP that Florida
has become and not really suffer when it comes
to polling and when it comes to approval.
That seems now to have changed.
And that is very good news.
Rhonda Santos's poll numbers have started
to plummet as the covid numbers in Florida
continue to get worse and worse and worse.
And what impact this will have on his gubernatorial
reelection campaign and possibly his eventual
candidacy for the Republican presidential
nomination.
We just don't know.
But let's look at this report from Truthout.
Florida Governor Rhonda Santurce is seeing
approval ratings plunge after enacting and
seeking to enforce stringent measures to prevent
schools in Florida from taking actions to
prevent the spread of coronavirus.
Earlier this year, DeSanto signed a bill into
law that banned local governments, including
school districts, from issuing rules about
masking, despite a CDC recommendation that
every school require masking to prevent students
and staff from contracting and spreading covid-19.
After several school districts said they would
keep their masking rules in place, dissenters
threatened to withhold the pay of district
officials in punishment for their defiance,
even though they were acting in the interest
of public health.
The Santas went forward with the threats despite
polling in a state showing that most people
support policies made at the local level to
keep masking in place.
In fact, most Americans back masking requirements
in schools in Florida is no different.
Around 62 percent of Florida voters support
rules requiring masks for students and staff.
Now new polling shows the Santas may have
harmed himself politically over his stubborn
stance on masking a political matrix.
Listener group survey asked Florida residents
where they whether they have a positive or
negative view of the governor on his handling
of the pandemic.
Only 43 percent say favorable 53, almost 54
percent say unfavorable.
Importantly, this puts the Santas at a disadvantage
against his potential political opponents.
He's up for reelection in 22.
In a hypothetical matchup against U.S. Congressman
Charlie Crist, the Santas would lose the governorship
43 to 57.
And DeSantis is also polling faring poorly
against the Florida agriculture commissioner,
Nick Friede.
Fred would win about 54 to 46.
We have this new polling data.
It is very interesting to look at.
This is the poll that's referred to and we'll
go through some of the numbers.
First one rating, the handling of the pandemic.
The Santos has 54 percent either unfavorable
or very unfavorable.
When you break it out by party lines, Republicans
are still strongly supportive.
Sixty to sixty six point two percent have
a combined, favorable and very favorable.
The poll goes on to find.
Next, we see a complete flip from eight weeks
ago with today Charlie Crist leading to Santos,
57 to 43.
What seems to be the biggest part is the amount
of grasp each has within their party.
With Democrats, Crist has almost 90 percent
of his base with Republicans to Santos is
down to only 75 percent of Republican responders.
So that's an important signal.
And that's similar actually to what we saw
with Donald Trump, where you saw Joe Biden
going into the 2020 election carrying almost
every Democrat, whereas Donald Trump was still
carrying a majority, but a smaller majority
of Republicans.
And of course, we know how that ultimately
turned out.
So, you know, this really shouldn't be news
like this is what we call logical.
When people's opinion reflects and responds
to what takes place in the real world, that's
logical and that makes sense.
We've become so used to seeing Republicans
reward the worst people and the worst political
performance that in a way, we're sort of like
surprised.
Wow.
DeSanctis has ruined Florida over covid and
his approval rating is plummeting.
It makes sense, but it still surprises us.
Now, someone wrote to me and said, you know
what's going on, David?
Ron DeSantis, his supporters are dying of
covid, so he's losing approval.
That's the math.
Doesn't check out on that for now, but it
could over time where you could actually start
to see the fact that it's disproportionately
Republicans who were dying of the virus because
it's disproportionately the unvaccinated who
are dying of the virus.
It could start to make a difference.
And what I mean by that is as of about 10
days ago, 1500 vaccinated people have died
of covid nationally.
And meanwhile, a thousand people a day are
dying.
So total 1500 vaccinated.
But every day a thousand are dying, overwhelmingly
the unvaccinated.
Over time, you could see a state like Florida
where Rhonda Santurce only won by 33000, but
it now has 42000 covid deaths.
It's conceivable you could get to a point
where the death partizan gap could cost Rhonda
Santurce reelection.
A lot more people would have to die because
remember, not everybody votes.
So of the 42000 that died, probably about
half are actual voters, maybe even less.
And then within that, you have to look at
the partizan split.
It might only be a seven or eight thousand
dollar sorry, seven or eight thousand death
gap between parties.
So very rough estimate, unless you see 120000,
140000 dead in Florida with a big partizan
gap.
I don't know that it would actually lead to
the Santurce losing because his voters died.
But the fact that we're even talking about
how far are we from that math making sense
tells you how insane the situation has become
in Florida.
If you're in Florida, let me know what the
mood is there.
Let me know what 2022 is looking like.
That's a big if.
Democrats were able to hold California in
the recall and take Florida in 2022, it would
be a really big deal heading into 2024.
Let me know your thoughts.
You can find me on Twitter at David Pakman.
Remember that if you like this show, or at
least sort of you can get more of it every
day, we do an extra show called The Bonus
Show for our website members.
Every single day you can sign up at join Pakman
dotcom coupon code available, not mandatory,
better.
Twenty one, save yourself about 40 percent.
And also you can get the commercial free audio
and video stream of the show every day as
a website member.